to present the Foreign Language Film
Award here is a Hollywood Nick who has
traveled widely as an actor and as an
ambassador for our community
in fact he flew in from East especially
for this event and his plane was late in
landing they had to circle the field for
an hour because of an emergency the
movie wasn't over here is former Oscar
winner Gregory Peck
we're told it was a Chinese who observed
that one picture is worth a thousand
words each frame of most of a motion
picture film as a picture in itself
there are 16 frames in a foot of film
the average movie is that say 80 100
feet that would be 120 9600 separate
pictures but the Chinese is right and
why should we dispute in a movie is
worth 129 million six hundred thousand
words whether those words are Greek
Swedish Japanese Italian or Czech and
reduced to motion pictures they speak a
common language and serve to illuminate
the land of their origin explaining
folkways presenting points of view
illustrating that humanity is in the
final analysis but one family for the
best foreign language film of the year
the Academy has nominated these five
from Greece blood on the land at Thanos
Thomas quino's and Viktor Michael Eady's
Tino's film production from Sweden Dear
John an a B Sam brew Studios production
from Japan quite on a Toho Company
production from Italy murids Italian
style a champion Concordia production
and from Czechoslovakia a shop on Main
streets a Czechoslovakia film production
now the envelope please
winner is Czechoslovakia for the chef
exceptin for chess Kozlov in ski films
Jan kadar co-director of the John on
Main Street
I am very very happy and deeply moved I
should like to thank all member of
Academy or voters of Academy and all
friends who have helped our film such a
lot Real Estate's uncle Oscar is the
highest appreciation not only for us
personally but for who our
cinematography thank you and I'm sorry
for my English